our next topic
is linear equations or really systems of
linear equations
which are very conveniently represented
using matrix vector notation
so a set of linear equations uh it's a
set of
m linear equations in n variables and
the variables are going to be called by
well by tradition but they could be
called anything
x1 up to xn um and there's m equations
each equation looks like this
it's a it's a set of coefficients it's
like capital a 1 1
x 1 plus a 1 2 x 2 up to a 1 and x n
equals b 1. so that's like one scalar
linear equation is the way people call
it okay
and so i have m of those um and here if
we
collect these x's into uh a vector
called x that's called the variable or
the unknowns
in the in the equation a
i j that these are these coefficients in
here those are called the coefficients
in the system of linear equations and if
you form a matrix
a which in this case is m by n
that matrix is called the coefficient
matrix of your system of linear
equations
b that's the vector over here if i
collect the b's into one vector it's
called
the right-hand side now that's a bit
silly
because it could just as well have been
the left-hand side but
by tradition it's called the right-hand
side
and this system of equations can be
written in very compact
uh matrix vector notation as ax equals b
okay so um that's some pretty powerful
notation there right because this could
be
i could write a x equals b that's four
characters right a
x equals and b and i could be referring
to
an equation with five 000 variables
and you know 3 000 equations right in
which case it'd be a whole lot of this
would be a whole lot of
equations and stuff um by the way the
note
you know that it's supposed to evoke
uh the same idea for in another context
in this case for example if a and
x and b are scalars right you would call
this a linear equation of course a
solution is very silly
it's x equals you know b over a
that's if they're scalars that's the
case m equals n equals 1.
uh of course this has no meaning
whatsoever uh
when when these are vectors and matrices
we will see the correct analog of this
equation
later but that's later in the course for
now we're just talking about
representing a set of linear equations
beautifully compactly with matrix
notation ax equals b
packs there's a lot of information in
in that okay now
we classify sets of linear equations
depending
on the size of a the dimensions of a
so it's called underdetermined if m
is less than n that means that the
coefficient matrix is
wide it has more columns than it has
rows now remember that the columns
of the co of the coefficient matrix are
associated with the variables
the x's the x i's the rows
are associated with the actual
individual scalar equations so that's
how that works
and underdetermined says roughly
speaking
there are fewer equations than there are
variables okay it's called the system is
called a square
system if they're equal if m equals n
that means
there's you know there for example
there's 20 variables
20 equations okay so that's called a
square system of a linear equations
and it's called over determined if there
are more equations than there
are unknowns and that means that the
coefficient matrix a
is tall and an example would be
i have 10 variables and i have 20
equations
and that's called over determined these
will be these names will become clearer
later as well now a vector x is called a
solution
if ax equals b that means it satisfies
all the linear equations you have
okay now depending on a and b
uh there can be either no solution
uh one solution or
many solutions right and so all three of
these are possible
um and and we'll have a pretty complete
analysis of that but by the end of the
class
we'll also much more importantly be able
to see how to actually
compute a solution and certainly we'll
be able to calculate
the solution when there is only one
again that's later in the class but for
now we're just talking about linear
equations
so we'll see later actually how to solve
them
all right so we're going to look at an
example and it's just to show
you how let's just show you an example
of linear equations
this one is taken from very elementary
chemistry which i took
i don't know 40 years ago maybe more
okay anyway
let's go on so a chemical reaction
actually i think it's longer okay
a chemical reaction involves uh let's
say p
reactants and q products um each of the
reactants is a molecule
um and each of the products is also a
molecule um
and you it's written this way you write
a1
r1 now plus dot plus aprp
goes to or in the reaction becomes
b1 p1 plus up to bq pq now
this this these are not you know that's
that's not multiplication of numbers
right this
it's a different notation system and
what it says
is uh what this declares is that you
have a bunch of reactants
um and they come together and some
chemistry happens and then what happens
is
you would take a1 units of reactant 1
a2 units of reactant 2 up to ap units of
reactant p and the unit could be for
example literally molecules right
and then what happens is well the
chemistry happens then and then what
what happens when
when the chemistry is done is you end up
with b1 units of p1
uh that's your product number one up to
bq
units of a product of the last q
of the last product okay so that's
that's how that works
um and then these a's are and b's are
positive coefficients now
they're they're generally integers um
but in fact
this the reaction is the same if you
multiply it by any by it by any positive
number
right so if you multiplied all the
coefficients by half
it would be describing the same uh the
same reaction
the same chemical uh equation okay so
that's that's
that's the idea here let's look at a
very simple example
uh which is electrolysis of water so
okay
so here uh here's the here's the
equation
uh the the so-called chemical equation
and it says that this says uh so on the
left
there is one reactant it's water h2o
uh now that of course means that water a
water molecule consists of two hydrogen
atoms and one oxygen atom
right so that's that's the chemical
notation by the way
if you don't know this it's fine no
problem this is just an example of a set
of linear equations so
you do not need to know chemistry trust
me i don't
well i did at one point a long long time
ago
so you don't need to know this is just
supposed to be an example
okay so this says on the left there's
one reactant it's a water molecule it's
h2o
and on the right we get two molecules uh
we get
hydrogen and oxygen those are gases and
it's uh these are molecules right so
h by itself is a hydrogen atom h sub
two is a hydrogen gas molecule and same
for o2 i mean doesn't that big acid but
it's hydrogen it's a hydrogen molecule
okay
um so we get two products which is
hydrogen the molecule h2
and oxygen that is o2 okay
and what this reaction says is that it
takes
two water molecules that's two of the
h2o
and something happens well in fact quite
specifically electrolysis happens
and it produces two hydrogen molecules
and one
oxygen molecule okay so that's uh that's
what this reaction says
okay so that's an example of a chemical
equation so equations chemical equations
uh
uh should be valid they have to be
balanced right um
which corresponds basically to this
conservation of
mass of the different well the different
types of atoms
so the idea is that each molecule in
either the reactant or the product
contains specific numbers of atoms uh
and that's given in its chemical formula
so for example here's a water molecule
and each water molecule contains two
hydrogen atoms and one oxygen atom
so that's two h and one o okay now
conservation of mass says that i mean
assuming this is not some crazy like you
know nuclear
fusion fusion reaction it basically says
that
the um the total number of
each atom among the reactants
should exactly balance the number of
atoms
that come out in the products okay and
so that that's kind of the idea and that
says the equation must
balance okay so
and that means for example for each atom
that comes in either the reactants or
products
the total on the left-hand side has to
equal the total on the right-hand side
so when we write down uh when we write
down
uh electrolysis that's two
uh h2o let me go back to it it's yeah
okay it's two h2o goes to two
uh let's see where is it it's 2h2
plus o2 then we check right on the
left-hand side
there's two water molecules each water
molecule has two hydrogen atoms so the
total number of hydrogen atoms on the
left-hand side among the reactants
is four hydrogen atoms now on the right
um
the number of hydrogen atoms is there's
two hydrogen
molecules each of those has two hydrogen
atoms so i got four
so everything's cool i had four hydrogen
atoms on the left
four on the right the left being the
reactants the right
being the products okay and you can
check also that there's two oxygen atoms
on the
on the left and two on the right or you
would say
two oxygen atoms among the reactants and
among the products is two oxygen atoms
as well uh
and they're they are found in one oxygen
molecule
okay now if i give you the
the if i give you uh the constituents
the reactants and the products
um there's the task of figuring out
what are the coefficients that that that
lead to balancing
okay so that's called balancing chemical
equations
okay so we're going to set that up and
show how we'll write that as a system of
linear equations
now we can't yet solve systems of linear
equations but don't worry
that's coming later in the course
actually not even that much later it's
coming
okay so what we're going to do is uh so
this is just an example to show
how do we set up a practical thing like
balancing chemical equations how do we
set that up as a set of linear equations
okay so what we're going to do is we
consider a reaction with
m types of atoms p reactants and q
products
and i'll make a reactant matrix i'll
call that r
and r i j is the number of atoms of type
i
in reactant rj okay
and so that's a matrix and that's a
beautiful matrix right it tells you it's
highly interpretable right if you look
at the
rows uh the a
a a row corresponds to a fixed uh you
know
it tells you about the atoms and how
they
uh actually how many of a certain type
of atom i
appears in all the reactants a column
tells you about
it basically tells you you know what is
reactant uh
what does that reactant consist of right
um so super interesting by the way the
matrix r could be sparse
that's super interesting that means that
most of the reactants
only involve only contain
a few of the atom types for example okay
all right um and we'll let a be the
vector of
reactant coefficients
then if i multiply r by a the matrix r
by a
i get basically the vector of the total
numbers of atoms of each type
in the reactants okay so if i've got
i i here have i have m uh
what i do is is i i have the the total i
get the total number of each type
of atom in all of the reactants put
together that's r times
a okay now we'll we'll define
a a product matrix the same way and so
it will have
and you know the entries are typically
integers that doesn't matter to us
okay and then in a similar way p times b
that's matrix vector multiplication
is a way to calculate all of the number
the numbers
uh the numbers of each of the different
types of atoms that you would get in
all the products together including by
the way the coefficients in front of
them
conservation of mass then comes down to
this super compact formula it says
r a equals p b that's a vector equal
with uh m e the left and right hand side
is an m vector
where m is the total number of atoms
appearing in your equation
okay so that's what it is it's it looks
like this so r a equals p b
okay so balancing is this equation in
matrix vector notation
now we're going to write this as
a a system of linear equations for the
coefficients and we'll start
by writing it this way remember that r
a equals p b expresses balance
and we're going to first write that as r
a
minus p b equals zero
and then finally we're going to write
that in block matrix notation as
this is a block matrix here
r uh concatenated aft you know
horizontally concatenated with minus p
times a stacked on top of b okay so now
you have to remember that when you
stack what we know that when you do
these stacks it all works out so this is
literally
r a minus p b equals zero and that
that's exactly what this
is but we write it this way okay
now unfortunately that is that's a
that's a bona fide set of linear
equations now unfortunately
uh a equals b equals zero is uh
satisfies that set of that that equation
now there's nothing wrong with that that
simply says
that if i take zero of all the reactants
then and i get zero of all the products
and that definitely works right because
you know
there's certainly an equal number of
hydrogen and carbon and nitrogen and so
on atoms
on the in the reactants and the products
which is zero in all cases
but it's not interesting and doesn't
help us to find a non-zero solution
we're going to set
one of the coefficients like a1 that is
the
number of the first reactant the number
of molecules
that go into your reactants i'm just
going to set that to be one okay
then i can express i'm going to do some
more stacking and
i'm going to write here this way i get a
big matrix here which is
r minus p this the height of this
is m the height of this part is 1.
i'm going to stack it as e 1 transpose
with 0 next to it when i multiply this
out i get e 1 transpose a
a 1 is e1 transpose a
so so this is a
a that's a set of equations uh e m plus
one
um the right hand side is got a zero all
zeros and a one at the bottom
and so you could say from this set this
is a set of
m plus one linear equations in p plus q
variables
and the first m equations give you the
balance
the last equation says that you're
simply going to take
one reactant of r1 one unit of r1 that's
all in your in your thing
okay now we don't this this equation
doesn't take into account the fact that
these are non-negative integers but
let's not worry about that okay
um now you also have conservation of
charge so
uh for example if i if these are ions
and i put a char
i can put a charge uh i actually forgot
what this is it's
some kind of chromium i don't know i
don't know but it doesn't matter but if
the two minus above it says it's got a
charge
of minus two so it's got a uh it's got a
surfa it's got a um
it's got more electrons than it has
protons and so it's got a charge of
minus two
conservation of charge also says that
it's not just the constituent atoms
but also the charge has to balance on
each side of the equation and so
charge simply becomes another type of
atom to balance
it's it's very simple okay so now we'll
do
um well a pretty hairy example and um
i'm i don't mind saying that i have
absolutely no idea what this equation
uh what this chemical uh equation tells
us or this chemical reaction is
i imagine it's an important one okay in
any case
let's see what it is basically there are
three reactants
there's this one uh this one which has
something with chromium or something
like that
that's that's something like it that's
not that's iron that that much i do
remember
um and that's a that's a hydrogen uh
atom actually with its electron ripped
off uh so
it's got a it's a it's a hydrogen ion um
okay
and then on the other side we've got you
know the the uh maybe
the atomic chromiums i don't i shouldn't
say anything because anything the same
is gonna be
people gonna make fun of me so it's fine
which i which doesn't bother me by the
way it's fine
um okay and then we have another one
uh which is um which is which is iron
over here on the other side and then we
have water
okay so that much i know fine
so there's five atoms um and
uh there's five atoms or charge right so
you have you know chromium oxygen iron
hydrogen and charge okay um
now the reactant and and product matrix
uh
you can these you the coefficients you
read off from these numbers here like
cr2
o7 2 minus these just that just reads
right into your reactant matrix
there is your product matrix
and remember that the height of this is
uh
is going to tell us is is the number of
uh constituent atoms and the last one is
going to give you charge
okay so uh okay if you want we can audit
one of these right
like well maybe we don't need to it's
fine um
okay now if we work out if we do exactly
what we
worked out over here very abstractly
right here
this one we we just simply write up this
big equation
and we get this set of equations right
here
and it's a square system of equations
there are six
unknowns which are the three reactant
numbers
uh the the three uh product
numbers um and we have a set of six
equations now it's a bit silly because
we know
instantly what a one is because this
bottom equation here
says that a1 is one right so but
nevertheless
this we've just written this as you know
ax equals b
um this is the matrix a it's six by six
it's square
this is you know quote x and this is b
and you have to
you have to forgive me because that
clashes with our notation b
for for the vector of reactants but
still this is the idea it's a big matrix
times a vector is equal to another
vector
okay um now this you can
solve we're not saying yet how to do
that
you can probably guess well it doesn't
matter you may have even seen it before
um pretty soon in the course you will
know how to solve linear equations
and uh when you solve this set of linear
equations
you get if you're lucky it has
one solution and that solution
turns out to be 1 6 14 2 6
7 and there's there's your balanced
equation right there
and you can check that the you know the
total number of hydrogens is hydrogen
atoms is the same on each side
we could check that sure on the left
hand side you have 14 hydrogen atoms on
the right hand side you also have 14
because you have
two per water molecule and you've got
seven water molecules 14.
we could check i don't know you know
charge maybe that's like um
you know what forget it it balances
right that's it
um so these are the coefficients now you
could have found this by just messing
around
uh i mean it's not that hard to solve a
set of equations like this especially
with a whole lot of zeros
i'm talking about by hand right but
nevertheless later
we will we'll see very organized ways
not by the way not just to solve six by
six
sets of linear equations but you'll be
able to solve 600 by 600 sets of linear
equations and you'll be able to do that
super fast uh that that's kind of
something very important about this
class
we will get to that later so this is
nothing but an example i don't care
about chemistry actually i've forgotten
all the chemistry i ever learned which
was very very little and it was a long
time ago
so just remember this is just an example
to show how
in some applied area systems of linear
equations comes up
they come up in many many other areas
and like for example mechanical
equilibrium
all in economics they it comes up it
comes up
in many many many fields
you